this video is brought to you by
brilliant get a free trial with
brilliant and take advantage of its
hands-on stem learning lessons more on
them in a bit
[Music]
in the twilight of imperial rule a woman
rose to power in china who would
transform the middle kingdom yanara
singh better known as dowager empress
was as clever as she was ambitious born
into a respectable dish family she
became a low-ranking concubine in the
forbidden city only to work her way up
to the very top through a combination of
intrigue cunning and constantly
underrated intelligence she rose through
a male-dominated world to become the
most powerful person in china and should
use that power to transform the empire
as a woman behind the throne seiji
unleashed a wave of modernization that
upended the late qing dynasty under a
40-year reign china opened up itself to
the west began to industrialize and even
made moves towards democracy yet for all
the undoubted good she did there was
also a dark side to the dowager empress
implicated in a number of assassinations
swept up in the bloody horrors of the
boxer rebellion sichi walked a fine line
between enlightened leader and
cold-blooded machiavellian today
biographies is investigating the story
of the ordinary girl who became imperial
china's matriarch
there's no curse attributed to ancient
china which supposedly goes may you live
in interesting times none could have
known it at the moment of a birth but
the girl who would become sichi was
destined to live through some of the
most interesting times in history born
yahenara singh on november 29 1835
sichu's early life is shrouded in
mystery almost no formal records of her
first 16 years exist leaving us to piece
together what we can from later sources
we know that she was a manchu part of
the minority ethnic class that had ruled
majority han china since the 1660s we
know too that her father was a mid-level
government official the sort of guy who
could give his family a comfortable life
in a nice part of beijing we also know
that she was born at a point when china
was about to embark on an unprecedented
era of crisis in 1839 when sichi was
just four the first opium war would see
china trounced by the british beginning
a multi-decade series of conflicts civil
wars rebellions and outside interference
known as the century of humiliation but
while the first opium war passed little
tsuchi bai she would soon find herself
at the epicenter of the wave of coming
conflicts and speaking of si chi now
might be a good time to make a quick
note on names si chi was the name given
to the girl born yahanara singh once she
reached the position of dowager empress
sort of like how in ancient rome
octavian became emperor augustus but
since sichi received a new name almost
every time she changed ranks there's
just no way that we're going to be able
to use the chronologically correct ones
without confusing the hell out of
absolutely everybody so in the interest
of making things simple we're just going
to call her cichi throughout also
regarding the pronunciation of her name
i did look it up there are some
conflicting ones but i went with my main
pronunciation dictionary which says cg
so
here we are everybody as a girl in qing
dynasty china tsuchi grew up learning
ladylike pursuits which meant that she
could paint and play chess but was never
taught to read or ride yet even at this
young age there were signs she wouldn't
be bound by traditional gender roles
when sichi was a pre-teen the dao guang
emperor announced that serious money was
missing from the imperial treasury
rather than try and find the culprit he
ordered anyone who'd ever worked there
to shoulder part of the debt a
description that unfortunately included
one of cicci's ancestors with the debt
passed on to living relatives her father
was in danger of being thrown in prison
according to legend though sichi went
out and somehow managed to raise 60
percent of the debt in loans from that
point on the story goes her father
valued her opinion as highly as he would
a son kind of a backhand compliment
today but a serious deal in a society
that ranked women equal to
well a comfortable armchair not that
sichi suffered as badly as most women of
her era as a manchu she was exempt from
the painful hand traditional foot
binding a practice she had banned in
later life but while sichi's ethnicity
would save her feet from being mutilated
the same can't be said of a soul in 1850
the old emperor died and was replaced
with the shia feng emperor this began
imperial china one of the new emperor's
most important tasks was modernizing his
empire anything silly like that but
rather choosing his new harem so when
she turned 16 si chi like every manchu
girl was summoned to the capital to
partake in an absurd face-to-face
version of hot or not in a courtyard of
the forbidden city she was made to stand
with hundreds of other women while
xiafeng strutted up and down trying to
decide who to get jiggy with in the end
it was her eyes that did it every
account ever written of cici notes how
enthralling her eyes were evidently the
emperor thought so too that day si chi
was one of 10 women chosen for xi'an
feng's harem she moved into the
forbidden city on june 26 1852 as a
low-ranking concubine yet before a
decade was out she'd have managed to
claw her way to the very top
[Music]
for a teenage girl used to if we believe
the legends being treated as equal as a
boy life in the forbidden city must have
been unbearably strange to cj on the one
hand she was given maids and eunuchs to
attend to her and she'd lived with the
other concubines in a grand set of
sweets on the other hand the men in her
life had gone from seeing her as almost
as good as a boy to a pretty sex robot
that was only good for one thing once
while she was with the emperor sichi
made the mistake of trying to use her
giant brain to suggest ways the army
might overcome the deadly typing
rebellion roiling china's south but
rather than being all like whoa this
chick is uh pretty smart shifeng was
like
a girl
given a man advice please gods in some
tellings the emperor was so angry he
signed sichi's death warrant which means
the fact that this video isn't about to
end right now was down to one person on
the same day that sichi's eyes had
caught the emperor's attention another
concubine had been admitted to the
palace called zhen but known to history
asean she'd been elevated to the rank of
empress rather than a source of jealousy
between the two women their different
statuses would save cg's life when she
found out about the death warrant cian
went to the emperor and laid it on sick
exactly what she said is unknown but it
likely involved a whole lot of flattery
and also the suggestion that maybe just
maybe an intelligent outspoken concubine
might be more useful alive
than dead whatever she said it clearly
worked not only did the emperor forgive
sichi he promoted her boosting her from
his sixth rank concubine to number five
again to our ears that probably sounds
like a bit of a veiled insult but in
imperial china where rank was everything
it represented a massive boost in her
fortunes she even got a new name from
her original concubine name of lan or
orchid she became ye exemplary but this
would have nothing on the boost she'd
received soon after like many global
dynasties of the era the qing were
obsessed with producing male heirs
unfortunately xi'an feng was struggling
like hell to sire any boys so when cg
gave birth to a child on april 27th 1856
and it turned out to be a little dude
with a pee pee for the ching it was
party time the birth of baby zaichan
when cigi was just 20 years old
catbolled at her from only alive thanks
to cyan to second most important woman
in the country while chinese custom and
empress sian was legally considered the
mother being the concubine who burst the
air still carried a whole ton of cloud
sichi was promoted first to rank four
then with no more concubines producing
male layers right up to rank three noble
consort it was the beginning of her rise
to power one that would only accelerate
when her biological son
became the emperor and it turned out
that was going to happen a whole lot
sooner than anybody anticipated the same
year zion was born the british launched
their wholly unwanted sequel to the
original opium war like any good
blockbuster the second opium war was
bigger crazier and above all else a
cynical attempt to make its creators as
much money as humanly possible as the
typing rebellion continued to pull china
apart the british sent diplomats to
negotiate a brutally one-sided piece in
retaliation the emperor had them all
arrested so the british did what they
did best they burned down one of the
seats of government the 1860 attack on
the summer palace came just as people
gathered to celebrate the emperor's 30th
birthday sichi cyan and more were forced
to flee ahead of an orgy of looting and
burning in the wake of the palace's
destruction what other choice did the
emperor have broken crushed jianfeng
dispatched his brother prince gong to
make peace the resulting treaty saw
china humiliated swathes of territory
were lost europeans were given
staggering concessions in trade and
religious freedom and exemptions from
chinese laws for an emperor who'd grown
up despising the west it must have been
a bit of a bitter pill to swallow
fortunately jianfeng wouldn't be around
to witness the aftermath in august 1861
the emperor began coughing up blood
after a short illness he passed away
leaving only a single male heir and just
like that young cg found herself mother
of the new emperor now just before we
continue with today's video let me tell
you about today's fantastic sponsor
brilliant brilliant for those who don't
already know is a website and app built
on the idea of active problem solving
because it takes more to learn something
than just watching it to really learn
something you actually have to do it you
have to practice it which is why
brilliant has tons of lessons on its
platform for lifelong learners who
aren't just content to coast through
adulthood with the skills that they
learned in school for example have you
ever wanted to learn how computer
programming works but were put off by
intimidating an opaque coding language
well brilliant help you learn how to
program without having to dig deep
through the weeds of coding syntax this
is thanks to fun interactive challenges
brilliant users can shift around blocks
of pseudo code that then get immediate
feedback on their results it's an
engaging way to understand how computer
algorithms work and once you've got that
down the coding syntax becomes just a
lot less intimidating on brilliant it's
not about memorizing or regurgitating
facts for a test you can just pick a
course you're interested in and get
started feeling stuck afraid you made a
mistake it's never an issue with
brilliant you can just read the
explanation to find out more and learn
at your own pace so if you're a lifelong
learner who wants to give brilliant a
try you guys can get a free trial plus
20 off the cost of a year subscription
by following the link in the description
below and now back to today's video
uh of course this being the chinese
imperial court things weren't quite as
simple as little zai chan putting on a
crown and sigi suddenly becoming boss of
the palace on his deathbed jianfeng
signed a proclamation placing power in
the hands of eight men under his advisor
sushem the idea was that these men would
act as regents until the boy came of age
but since seshun was clearly plotting to
take control for himself tsichi asked
the emperor directly who would succeed
him when xianfeng replied with uh my son
obs well the stage was set for an epic
power struggle so here's the situation
as we go into battle on one side we have
the powerful advisor sushun and his
cabal of prominent men all favored both
politically and by their gender on the
other hand we have the recently elevated
dowager empress tsuchi and sian with a
bit of secret help from xianfeng's
brother prince gong the goal
to become official decision maker for
the
zai chun the new tongzi emperor the
prize well make yourself the most
powerful person in all of china and in a
real-life squad game like this there
could only be one winner at the moment
the starting gun was fired on this epic
show done smart money was on a social
victory after all he was important
connected a respected powerful male
going up against a former concubine you
can almost imagine him cackling like
dick dastardly as he declares don't
worry little lady this will hurt you
more than it hurts me but in this our
villain would be proven spectacularly
wrong for all society may have regarded
her as a mere concubine there was
nothing mere about cg she was shrewd
intelligent and don't forget versed in
chess from a young age and in the giant
three-dimensional chess game that sushen
didn't even know he was playing she
could see a bazillion moves ahead the
first smart thing cc and cian did was
getting everyone to agree to let them
write the royal seal in this era all
chinese laws had to be literally signed
off by the emperor but since xiaochung
was so young having the whole nation
weight on a five-year-old's handwriting
skills was a clear route to disaster so
si chi was all like yeah you know what
how about me and sian do it and just
save everybody the trouble yeah to which
sushen ascended probably while smirking
about how it fobbed her off with
trinkets but the power to make laws
actually legal obviously wasn't a
trinket at all still cicci couldn't just
write a letter saying feeds are shown to
the lions and sign it into law no no no
she needed a reason to take down her
nemesis which leads us up to her second
smart move making a child cry one day
when sushen and the regents were doing
their thing tsuji came up to them with
zeitung in tow she was then just so
objectionable the regents lost their
tempers and started shouting at her
which caused zychum to burst into tears
rather than whoops sorry my bad sichi
instead declared that the regents had
disrespected the young emperor and act
tantamount to treason it was around this
time that sushen began plotting to kill
her but his plans were too little too
late in november 1861 a 10-day funeral
procession was held for the dead
gianfeng
informs hashem that she'd only be
available for part of the ceremony but
that he should attend the whole thing
since it'd be a show of great respect
perhaps spooked by the whole bowling
emperor episode sushen agreed then while
he was out at the funeral si set up the
perfect checkmate during the ten days
sichi cyan and prince gong worked
feverishly to whip up palace sentiment
against the regions finally at the end
of the procession they unveiled a
proclamation in zeitung's name signed by
c.g seal and it charged them all with
treason sasham was arrested and
sentenced to death by a thousand cuts a
sentence chi commuted to death by
decapitation two other regions were
ordered to commit suicide and the rest
were stripped of their wealth and sent
into exile in the wake of the near
bloodless coup a second proclamation
went out this one declaring that cyan
and sichi with advice from prince gong
would now decide on all matters of state
and with that it was game set a match
aged just 26
cichi had done it along with cyan she
had outmaneuvered everyone to become the
most important person in china and
what's a sharp ambitious girl to do with
near unlimited power why transform her
country of course
[Music]
from the moment session was executed
sichi became effectively the ruler of
china a position that should hold all
the way through to 1908. yet thanks to
agenda that position would never be
official she would be treated as equal
to the emperors she ruled on behalf of
forced to sit behind a silk screen
during meetings and forbidden from
setting foot in front of the imperial
palace despite these limitations though
she'd wind up overseeing one of the most
transformative programs in chinese
history with prince gong focused on
practical matters and sian happy to stay
in the shadows it would be sichi who'd
make the major policy decisions perhaps
one of the most major was to pivot china
towards the west although the opium wars
were over now the taiping was still
causing chaos so sichi put aside the
humiliation of the unequal treaty signed
with britain france and others and
instead asked them for help modernizing
her army the british agreed and did such
a good job that the ching were finally
able to end the taiping rebellion in
1864 by which time some 20 million
people had died but this massive
military upgrade would turn out to be
only the beginning of china's westward
tills under the self-strengthening
movement trade was further opened up to
europe western schools were established
to teach european languages western
officials hired to clamp down on
corruption and graft advisors were
invited from the leading economies to do
everything from spearhead agricultural
reforms to teach the ching military how
to build modern weapons the result was a
slow but steady opening up a
transformation that saw china gain its
first modern navy postal service and
monetary system the first vestiges of
industrialization crept in two as mines
were opened and telegraph systems were
laid not that sichi's embrace of western
style modernity was absolute no matter
how hard outside investors tried they
couldn't get china to invest in
railroads tsuchi was just too adamant
that the noise would disturb ancestral
tombs dodged across the countryside it
would take until 1876 for her to get
permission for a single working line to
be laid by which time the political
conditions would have drastically
changed first there was the accidental
near war with france that came close to
crisis with china becoming stronger
plenty of sichi's advisers such as
prince gong's brother prince chun were
demanding that she used that new
strength to get revenge for the unequal
treaties when cigi demurred chun helped
orchestrate anti-christian riots riots
that saw french citizens lynched luckily
the disaster of the franco-prussian war
meant that france was less willing to
fight than usual and tsuchi managed to
mollify paris but the second shake-up
would be even bigger on january the 2nd
1875 zytrum died of smallpox not yet 20.
although he'd taken over as emperor when
he was 16 zychum still hadn't managed to
sire in air while his empress was
pregnant when he died her family ordered
her to starve herself to death in a show
of piety although rumors persist that cg
arranged the whole thing with no sun to
elevate the dying emperor handed the
power to choose his successor to sichi
the successor she chose prince chun's
three-year-old son now there are a
couple of different ways to read this
the first cynical one is that xichi and
sian weren't interested in stepping
aside and needed a new very young
emperor that they could rule in place of
since his son becoming emperor would
also force the annoying prince chun to
give up his duties that was two birds
with one stone the slightly kinder
reading is that the dowager empress was
hamstrung by convention unable to pick
anyone older than the dead emperor had
been and lacking any decent teenage
candidates either way chun's infant was
elevated to guangzhou emperor and sian
and sichi officially made his parents
while the boy was told to address sian
as his mother he was made to refer to
sichi as blessed father simple
expediency or cg signaling loud and
clear that she was as good as any male
well
we'll let you be the judge as the 1870s
closed then tsuchi was firmly ensconced
at the head of a powerful triumvirate
leading a rapidly modernizing nation
into the last years of the 19th century
yet comfortable as she was she couldn't
shield herself from all misfortunes and
the dawning of the new decade was going
to bring with it something the dowager
empress had never experienced before
real unimaginable tragedy
generally speaking popular sentiment has
seen sichi in one of two ways the first
is the more modern view as a strong
capable woman who created a brief oasis
of stability in a century of chaos the
other is as the chinese equivalent of
agropina a murderous she-devil who
murdered everybody who got in her way
which minion you subscribe to will
probably dictate how you feel about what
happens next on april the 8th 1881
succee's co-region xian suddenly died
aged just 43. for those of the cg
murdered everyone's school of chinese
history this is evidence that her lust
for power was growing causing her to
bump off her only rival but for those
who prefer
shade more nuance a kinder reading is
that this was the first time tsuji was
forced to face real tragedy from the
moment shid intervened with xi'an feng
to save the older woman's life cyan had
been suchi's one constant ally her
friend a confident a protector to
suddenly be without her must have been
like waking up one day to find your legs
have vanished a shock you can't ever
imagine recovering from certainly sian's
exit seems to have destabilized the
dowager empress the ears that followed
saw the reforming zeal of the 1870s give
way to a kind of directionlessness as
sichi refused further industrialization
and got in a short inconclusive war with
france of vietnam and even ended up
firing her loyal lieutenant prince gong
finally in 1889 it seemed as if had
enough as the guangzhou emperor reached
maturity the 54 year old cece announced
that she was stepping down there'd be no
new child emperor no attempt to cling to
power just a peaceful retirement to an
expensive recreation of the summer
palace to wait out the end of her days
at least that was the plan as can be
seen throughout human history though
once someone has been in power too long
it can be hard for them to let go
especially if their successor isn't up
to scratch and guangzhou was all too
aware of his weaknesses even once made
emperor prince chun's son would meet
sichi several times a week to seek her
advice a habit but soon led his own
advisors to basically say screw it why
don't we just get this and just go and
talk directly to see jim now this
arrangement wasn't necessarily fatal not
if gwangju and sichi were pulling in the
same direction but what if there was
some say gigantic catastrophe that
pushed them in opposite directions well
in 1894 that catastrophe blew up in the
shape of the first sino-japanese war
we'll likely cover this over on our new
channel wara graphics one day go over
and subscribe to that so we'll keep
things rather simple here and the
simplest version is that china got its
arse
absolutely whipped in the aftermath of
this latest humiliation guangxi became
convinced that si chi's reforms hadn't
gone far enough that china needed to
modernize now to stand any chance of
catching up with its belligerent
neighbor so against sichi's wishes the
emperor launched 100 days reform in 1898
determined to upend society
instead he brought about his own
downfall always against these reforms si
chi was told by our advisors that
guangzhou had become a puppet of japan
so with a coldness matched only by her
competence she launched a coup the
emperor was arrested imprisoned on an
island his fellow reformers were
executed or else they fled to tokyo by
the time the dust settled the reform era
was definitively over once again china's
matriarch was in charge this time though
it would be the aging dowager impress
herself who'd wind up unleashing chaos
on her people
one reason people have so differing
opinions on cg is that there are few
instances where things are totally
clear-cut like maybe she killed her
rivals or maybe she didn't maybe she was
foolish to end the guangzhou emperor's
reforms but maybe her own reformist
history gives her a pass however there's
no ambiguity where the box rebellion is
concerned no matter how you cut it
sichi's response to the uprising
was a disaster launched in 1899 by the
epically named righteous and harmonious
fists the boxer rebellion was an
anti-western anti-christian insurrection
that ultimately killed a hundred
thousand people in the early stages
these deaths were westerners and chinese
accused of picking up western habits but
then the eight nation alliance of
austria-hungary the usa great britain
france italy germany japan and russia
they launched a joint invasion of china
to protect their citizens and
everything went absolutely nuts rather
than suppress the boxes tsuchi came out
on their side declaring a war for
survival against the eight nation
alliance this led to the alliance
attacking beijing where the boxers were
laying siege to foreign embassies
causing sichi and a court to flee it was
like the burning of the summer palace
all over again but while the british had
very much been at fault in 1860 in 1900
sushi had to shoulder at least some of
the blame the boxer rebellion ended in
1901 with an alliance victory and mass
execution of suspected rebels the treaty
then forced on china was so humiliating
it made even the ending to the second
opium war looked like mere fetish play
in comparison crippled by a gigantic
indemnity beijing was pushed toward
bankruptcy foreign troops were stationed
in the nation on a permanent basis but
one aspect of pre-rebellion life that
would survive was tsiti herself in 1901
tsuji issued the decree of self-reproach
blaming herself for the war she then
tried to make amends by ushering in
something called the late-ching reforms
an overhaul of the state that went
beyond even what the emperor had
attempted tax policing the judiciary
education were all completely upended
foot binding was banned into ethnic
marriages between bahana manchus
legalized a degree of press freedom
instituted by 1906 cichi was even
decreeing that china would become a
constitutional monarchy complete with
elections and degree of male suffrage
potentially the greatest reform the
nation had yet seen but in the end it
wouldn't be sichi's late life edicts
that had the greatest impact on history
but what she did on her final day in
1908 sichi fell badly ill tensing that
the end was near it seems she acted to
preserve her legacy on november the 14th
the guangzhou emperor died in his
luxurious prison a hundred days later
scientific analysis of his body would
confirm that he was poisoned with
arsenic did sichi bump him off we can't
say for sure maybe it was a wider
conspiracy in which her own illness was
also the result of poisoning but if any
of the deaths in this video could be
laid at her feet it's probably this one
surely after the airless emperor's death
sichi chose the man who would succeed
him or rather the boy prince chun's
two-year-old son poiyi famous today as
the last emperor mere hours later sushi
herself died on november 15 1908 she was
72. at the moment she passed suchi was
the grand matriarch of an empire that
had lasted in various forms for
thousands of years an empire that was in
need of reform certainly but making
steps in the right direction within
three years though all of that would
have been swept away in 1911 puyi would
be deposed in a revolution leading china
to collapse into the anarchy of the
warlord era a process that would
eventually lead to the rise of two
competing visions for the future that of
chiang kai-shek and that of mao zedong
but by then cg would have been lost to
history a tomb destroyed in 1927 a body
desecrated and then thrown away like so
much trash in the decades since the
daughter empress's reputation has been
on a wild ride from a figure of
revulsion she came to be seen as a
complex failure and more recently as a
strong admirable woman who did her best
to lead her country through a dark time
today we're finally in a position to
appreciate the nuances of her rule to
see clearly both the good and the bad
without a doubt she was a remarkable
figure a woman who rose to power in a
man's world and then proceeded to reform
imperial china in ways no man had ever
dreamed yet we also have to accept that
those reforms ultimately failed that she
stopped the last necessary steps under
the guangzhou emperor then left behind a
system that wouldn't survive another
half decade was she brilliant venal
inspirational destructive the truth is
that she was maybe all these things and
many more a woman who shaped the destiny
of a billion people in some areas
brilliantly in others such as the boxer
rebellion catastrophically what she
never was though was inconsequential for
both good and ill sichi shaped china for
nearly half a century and that alone
ensures that she'll never be forgotten
so i really hope you found today's video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe also as i mentioned wara
graphics new channel link below thanks
for watching
you